se cumplieron siete años de la primera
marcha el movimiento ninguna menos que
se creó tras el feminicidio de chiapas
en santa fe argentina el responsable fue
su novio manuel mancilla como
consecuencia miles de mujeres se
movilizaron en todo el país para así
poner en discusión la violencia machista
y para exigir medidas para ponerle fin a
las expresiones de odio por motivos de
género y una menos o fue la consigna que
logró convocar y sintetizar una
impotencia que se expandió en todo el
continente ya que en todos nuestros
países lamentablemente las mujeres están
expuestas a una misoginia en cualquiera
de sus dimensiones para ello entonces
quiero saludar a nuestra segunda
invitada del día ella es mariana
carbajal periodista escritora y
directora de cine feminista una de las
impulsoras del movimiento ni una menos
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 mariana le
pregunto entonces los logros de este
movimiento y cómo han cambiado las cosas
en estos siete años
qué tal buenos dias cuestan en principio
lo que se ha logrado es visibilizar la
violencia
hoy escucho con eco si me la pueden
corregir si ya ya ya ya ya se lo
corrigieron no sé si ya hay escucha
mejor
digo que en principio lo que se logró es
visibilizar la violencia y su expresión
más extrema los permisible tíos esto
favoreció por ejemplo entre las demandas
que había desde ese primer ni una menos
la creación de un registro de femicidios
oficial porque no lo había desde ese en
ese entonces lo registraban las
organizaciones de la sociedad civil en
base a los casos que salían publicados
en los medios de comunicación
ese mismo 2015 se creó en la corte
suprema en la argentina un registro de
femicidios que año a año va dando cuenta
de los casos de las causas que llegan a
la justicia por esa razón
en los otros de las cuestiones de lo que
éste logró fue
en los colegios en los clubes en los
sindicatos se empezará a hablar del tema
y se crearán áreas de género y de
diversidad para empezar a pensar las
políticas de cada uno de los espacios
las medidas las acciones desde una
perspectiva de género tomando en cuenta
que la igualdad histórica que atraviesa
a las mujeres y al colectivo del egb efe
y más y que es el caldo de cultivo la
otra cara de la violencia machista si
pensamos en logros del tiempo más
reciente el gobierno que asumió a fines
de 2019 creó un ministerio de mujeres
géneros y diversidad y se han creado ese
mismo ministerio en algunas de las
provincias que son los estados que
componen la argentina también y en
municipios esto es como el espacio que
busca dar respuesta inmediata desde las
políticas públicas
a la problemática de violencia pero
ampliamos la mirada no solo a la
violencia de género a sus expresiones
más diversas también empezamos a hablar
de lo que es el acoso callejero la
violencia en la política intentando dar
respuestas por supuesto siempre falta y
en la argentina seguimos teniendo de
acuerdo al último registro desde mis
tíos de la corte suprema- un femicidio
cada 35 horas lo que sí como buena
noticia es que
en el último registro se muestra un leve
descenso del 8% si se toma en cuenta las
víctimas directas de femicidio y del 13
posible 2 si usted toma en cuenta las
víctimas vinculadas a ese femicidio
muchas veces además de la de la mujer a
la que se quiere matar el agresor el
violento lo que hace es matar a otras
personas de relaciones a una hija a una
madre u otros que están en lo que se
llama la línea de fuego él se empezó a
hablar de el fútbol femenino de las
mujeres la posibilidad de jugar al
fútbol que tenían obstáculos también
digo se fue abriendo esa paleta esa lupa
mirando las desigualdades y sobre todo
se empezó a visibilizar
los temas de los cuidados clones porque
el eje de la desigualdad de género tiene
que ver con que las mujeres nos hacemos
mayoritariamente cargo de las tareas de
cuidado
domésticas pero cuidado y crianza de
nuestras hijas de nuestros hijos y eso
es también lo que éste puso en juego y
de hecho hay un en el congreso
actualmente un proyecto de el gobierno
que busca crear un programa integral de
cuidados y reconocer por un lado la
ampliación de licencias para padres
también para progenitores no gestantes
que se amplíe que en argentina
lamentablemente hoy los países que
tienen más corta estas licencias de
apenas dos días
y estamos debatiendo entonces empezando
a pensar de qué forma habilita armar
esta desigualdad que tiene que ver con
las tareas de cuidado y que forman parte
de las desigualdades que atraviesan a
las mujeres y a las diversidades en
argentina y en el mundo marian o incluso
en ese orden de días el presidente de
chile en su discurso digamos anunció
esta ley de cuidados para que sea más
inclusiva para que también no sean
solamente pues las mujeres que estén
encargadas de todos estos cuidados
entonces pues vemos que por lo menos en
chile ya se está avanzando en estas
leyes para poder lograr una igualdad y
que no solamente eso sea pues cuestión
de las mujeres y ahora hablando de
nuestra región mariana le quiero
preguntar cuáles son los países con más
violencia de género y de alguna manera
así se puede decir a qué se debe
los países centroamericanos
lamentablemente son los que tienen las
tasas más altas de femicidio y esto
tiene que ver con el machismo que
atraviesa la sociedad pero también con
la falta de políticas públicas en
relación para dar respuestas efectivas e
inmediatas a las mujeres estaba la
violencia contra las mujeres sobre todo
la violencia sexual también estaba muy
naturalizada conozco la experiencia en
el salvador sobre todo acabo de terminar
un documental sobre las consecuencias de
la criminalización absoluta del aborto
en el salvador y lo que se observa con
claridad es una naturalización atroz de
la violencia sexual sobre todo hacia las
niñas y a las adolescentes al punto que
hay hay registros de adolescentes que se
suicidan
recurriendo a veneno de ratas al
enfrentar estos embarazos forzados
productos de violaciones en el marco de
ataques de pandilleros entonces me
parece que ahí en el centro américa
tiene como un núcleo muy duro claire y
por la falta de respuestas de políticas
públicas desde el estado en responder y
dar respuestas efectivas a las mujeres
que denuncian y sobre todo pensando en
la prevención creo que de un eje central
para toda la región es profundizar la
educación sexual integral creo que esta
es la herramienta a largo plazo que nos
va a permitir
desarmar los machismos y la desigualdad
pensando sobre todo en las infancias y
vemos con mucha preocupación
que sectores anti de estos conservadores
fundamentalistas los mismos que en
estados unidos pretenden retroceder en
el derecho al aborto también están
trabajando
latinoamérica no muy articuladamente
para hacer retroceder en los avances que
hemos logrado